[Music]
positive noises are coming out of the
negotiations between ukraine and russia
with even an advisor to president
zelinski of ukraine are showing some
optimism what could that endpoint look
like and what more can the west do to
strengthen ukraine in the meantime
in this week's magazine the historian
timothy gardenash makes three
suggestions he joins the show now
so timothy thank you so much for joining
spectator tv in the magazine this week
you write about uh what the west can do
to help ukraine and you outline these
three options can you give us a brief
overview of them
absolutely i mean the question of
questions we've seen this heroic
extraordinary uh ukrainian resistance
how can we help them
three big things all of which come from
president zielinski in his tweets
number one more weapons
uh particularly air defense weapons and
supplies to help them resist a siege
because that's what's now happening in
almost
medieval siege of ukrainian cities
secondly more sanctions and
the big one here is oil and gas
at the moment germans and italians and
others in the eu are still paying
billions of euros effectively
into putin's war chest to pay their
heating bills um and and that would be a
really major move which would cost
countries like germany
very dear economically
but as i argue there's a moral cost to
not doing it right and then the third
big one which zelensky asks for
is
accept ukraine as a candidate for eu
membership and there i argue that the
eu's not going to do that anytime soon
but there are lots of big things we
including britain can do
to have a big reconstruction plan
and to bring ukraine gradually closer to
a european future
can i pick you up on sanctions first of
all which is that you say that is going
to be expensive uh for the germans i
think yeah it definitely will be um do
you think they're not going far enough
now then because they have already said
that they have already sanctioned some
of these russian companies not to the
extent that they're not importing uh the
resources but also that they've said
that they'll reduce russian gas by
two-thirds by the end of the year is
that not enough
how many ukrainians would have died by
the end of the year i think that's the
answer to the question listen because of
the big mistakes we all made in not
reducing energy dependence after the
caesar crimea in 2014 they're in a bind
make no mistake
30 percent of
germany's total primary energy supply
comes from russian oil
gas and coal it's enormous if they make
the stop
the estimated hit is between
one and three percent of gdp or one
thousand euros ahead so it's a big
economic cost
but as i say
are you really going to go on paying
putin with every heating bill
when ukrainians are being massacred in
the way they are but what is the
realistic middle point because you can't
just wean off overnight so
is it realistic for germans or any
europeans to do that
so interestingly the big profit maker
for russia is oil
so one way to do this
i is actually to start by stopping oil
imports and take a bit more time over
gas
um the good news is we're coming into
the summer you don't need so much energy
in the summer but you know what the
popular outrage in germany is so immense
as it is in britain that i think this
may yet happen
and timothy on the military front uh
nato has ruled out this no-fly zone as
zlensky is asking for citing concerns
that putin would use as justification to
attack nato but somehow people have
argued that putin clearly needs no
justification for aggression so it
doesn't really matter almost and if
zalensky's asking for it maybe we should
have that what do you make of that
argument well
what i say is
nato is not going to do it
that's what's clear and i mean they've
been already joe biden has been
absolutely clear about it jens
stoltenberg has been absolutely clear
about it so we could have a hypothetical
discussion about what would happen if
and the answer is
you know putin is capable of anything
but realistically it's not going to
happen and so we have to do everything
short of that mark and actually what i
gather from the experts is that if we
can get in
sophisticated uh uh
anti-aircraft air defense missiles
that's in a way as important as um
getting in those you know polish mig
planes or
a no-fly zone which would be a no-fly
zone only against the russians
and i want to talk to you about this
zielinski plan you're you're writing
about tell us about that
yeah um well i'm fed up with people
keeping saying you know we have a new
marshall plan because you know they've
been about i i can personally remember
about seven proposed martial plans that
never happened for former yugoslavia you
name it for east central europe uh so i
call it the zelinski plan but
listen the the the war damage is already
estimated at well over a hundred billion
dollars that's clearly an underestimated
the russians are still pounding away so
it's hundreds of billions and the least
we in the west can do
is to have a big reconstruction plan
and my argument is by the way that's
also rebuilding the homes to which the
millions of refugees
in the rest of europe will go home so
that's important for us too
but my argument is to connect it to some
intermediate steps of connecting ukraine
more closely to europe well it's a
fascinating idea and there's the
sweetener i guess to those concessions
that you allude to can we talk about how
this will end because it does seem like
zolensky may have to make some of these
painful concessions
so
as i say in the piece
i pray daily for a miracle on that
nipper
like the miracle on the vestila in
1920 when the poles defeated the
advancing red army and and the red army
simply retreated
but that would be a miracle
and barring miracles neither side can
win and therefore they're going to have
to fight their way
i'm afraid through rivers of blood sweat
and tears
to a point where there's what um
lawrence friedman the strategic thinker
calls a hurting stalemate when both
sides are hurting so much that they have
to make a deal and
only the ukrainians have the right to
say what that deal is
you know can be
but we can at least start thinking about
it now zielinski
yesterday
tuesday um we're speaking on wednesday
said
i don't think we're going to become a
member of nato so he's already in effect
saying okay we can go to neutrality
what's really painful is going to be the
territorial concessions crimea and
donetsk and luhans the provinces in the
in the far east of the country
and that that that's really tough to
take
would i mean let alone do you think the
ukrainian government the ukrainian
people would accept something like that
so i talk regularly to people connected
with the ukrainian government at the
moment the public position is no
but and of course
we should in no way shape or form be
kind of forcing this on them that we
have absolutely no right to do that
but privately they will acknowledge
you know these are facts on the ground
the comparison i draw with the so-called
winter war between finland and the
soviet union in 1939-1940
um
stalin thought he'd roll over finland as
putin thought he'd roll over ukraine in
fact the poo the finns put up the most
magnificent amazing military resistance
gave stalin the bloody nose
and basically six months later they
signed a piece
they had to give up about one tenth of
finnish territory brutal concession but
finland remained a free
sovereign independent democratic country
and i think every finn
you speak to would say that was a price
worth paying
and finally timothy i just want to end
on this note that you make about
zelinski um obviously his performance i
think throughout all of this i think
many people can agree has been exceeded
expectations of an actor or comedian
you also mentioned his twitter feed as a
master class in 21st century war
leadership tell us about that
so i
every viewer should
should follow him on twitter it's
absolutely amazing by the way when i
started he was just over 2 million
followers now he's well over 5 million
in the middle of this war in risk of his
life after every conversation with a
western leader biden or schultz or
macron boris johnson or whoever it is he
just has a tweet
saying what they talked about and doing
his main points then he does these video
clips
walking around besieged kiev
his messages to the ukrainian people and
the russian people it is an absolute
master class in political communication
and the effect is you know
the ukrainians have already won the
information war
the russians are still fighting the
military war but the information war
they've just won
hands down so it's like you know imagine
winston churchill with a twitter account
that's a great note to end on timothy
gardenash thank you very much for
joining spectator tv
[Music]
you